مرحبًا، أنا الدكتور سانجاي غوبتا مضيف
بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN، كلنا نريد
أن نحافظ على دماغنا حادًا، وإحدى الطرق
للمساعدة في إبطاء فقدان الذاكرة قد تكون عن طريق تناول
المزيد من مركبات الفلافونول، تذكر أن كلمة
فلافينول هي مضادات الأكسدة الموجودة في
العديد من الفواكه والخضروات والشاي والنبيذ.
تتبعت دراسة حديثة ما يقرب من ألف شخص
تتراوح أعمارهم بين 60 إلى 100 سنة لمدة سبع
سنوات لم تظهر أي علامات على الخرف إلى جانب
إجراء اختبارات معرفية وذاكرة سنوية،
كما قاموا بملء
استبيانات منتظمة حول ما
يأكلونه، ووجدوا أن الأشخاص في الدراسة
الذين تناولوا الأطعمة التي
تحتوي على أعلى كميات من الكافور المرتبطة
بأقل تراجع إدراكي مقارنة مع
أولئك الذين تناولوا أقل عدد من المصادر الجيدة
للكافورول، البصل، الهليون، التوت،
السبانخ، الكرنب، الخضروات الورقية الخضراء، لكن
الباحثين لا يتوقعون الحصول على
نفس النتائج من المعبأة في زجاجات.
الفلافونول أو مكملات الفلافونويد،
ما كان أساسيًا كما يقولون هو تناول
الأطعمة الكاملة المغذية، ويمكنك سماع
المزيد عن طرق تحسين صحتك
ومطاردة الحياة أينما حصلت على
ملفاتك الصوتية
[موسيقى]